ce papier cartonné ce qu'on voit encore
ça c'est quand j'ai vu ce que je suis en
vie surtout sur le plancher à 7 h des
surprises
c'est une requête en vue d'obtenir la
présence d'un détenu à la cour donc
c'est une copie carbone dans un document
qu'il faut fasciné par un juge ainsi ces
exemplaires et ensuite en personne il
faut aller au greffe à la détention et
au procès puisque comme par courriel
québec des blocs 289 millions de dollars
pour créer notamment deux plateformes
numériques qui pourrait vous toucher
directement si quelques années nous
sommes à allah à l'âge de pierre en
matière de preuves électroniques nous
sommes encore à l'âge du tapis un
guichet unique d'information juridique
sera rendu disponible sur le site web du
ministère
alors avant d'appeler un avocat vous
pourriez trouver là facilement une foule
de réponses à vos questions
on peut penser par exemple à une formule
de calcul pour une pension alimentaire
en cas de séparation ici c'est la guerre
civile et familiale donc c'est ici que
les gens peuvent avoir accès à leurs
dossiers déposés la procédure c'est le
seul endroit où ils peuvent aller points
0,12 fictivement le ministère veut aussi
créer un portail de services en ligne un
registre du greffe numérique où il sera
possible de déposer des documents et de
prendre des rendez vous c'est vraiment
un game challenge pour nous on va sauver
du tas si on prend le code une selle de
personnes qui veut contester une
contravention
si lui veut se représenter s'énerver
avec dans son sillage
comme on le voit souvent des photos qui
prouve son innocence
à l'heure actuelle il devra déposer soit
une copie paris soit une copie sur une
clé usb de pouvoir permettre un procès
de façon électronique numérique ça va
faciliter l'accès à la justice tous ceux
pourrait permettre de réduire les délais
déraisonnables le but
que les audiences se tiennent sans
papiers vous direz qu'il était temps
mais il faudra encore attendre quelques
années avant que toutes les plateformes
soit en place aux états unis les
changements ont pourtant commencé en